this is basically the last shot i've
done
everything that i possibly could to save
my marriage and he really thinks that
being in our own place will make him act
differently
what tell me this if asuelu would argue
with kalani
in her parents house why would he
conduct himself any better in a house of
their own
yet kalani is really considering
purchasing a home to save her marriage
is that the best idea
luckily she has a sister who loves her
enough to tell her the truth
but i want to give it this shot so that
if he doesn't then i could say look i
tried this
i tried this i tried this yeah but then
you have a whole ass house together
so isn't that even harder yes
especially when you know deep down that
the location
was never the issue we're gonna talk
about it plus
andre and his rude remarks are back
you're a
philosopher now if he gets on your
nerves just remember this
we don't have to deal with him that's
elizabeth's job
and i don't know how she does it smile
like you're successful
speaking of a job andre finally decided
to get one
this year i got my real estate license
and i'm planning to open my own business
into
flipping houses but there's a catch here
he had the audacity
to ask elizabeth's dad to loan him a
hundred
grand like a hundred grand maybe to
launch his business thing like are you
gonna
give me the money or not that's what
thing is mind you this is an
industry he has no experience in i
i don't even know what to say well i do
this is season six of happily ever after
and the shenanigans have
officially begun hey 90 day fans fam
it's melisa the series we've been
missing
is back and did y'all see what we have
in store for the season
this is what caught my eye we have
natalie saying
mike's mom called her a hooker send her
back
julia found herself in the middle of a
jealousy temper tantrum
in this fight between asuelu and
kalani's family
we don't like you anymore it feels so
wrong to say this but
i can't wait to see all this go down
hopefully everything ramps up pretty
soon
despite hitting rock bottom i don't
think either of us were really ready
to just give up all right first episode
we get a gist of where everyone stands
when it comes to oswell and kalani they
spend some time shopping for a new home
most of our properties come from living
with kalani and her family
i just want to have my own space aswell
revealed that he's ready to move out of
kalani's parents house because he feels
uncomfortable
and he just wants his own space
now we're excited to find our own place
and start this new chapter in our lives
i have a full-time job driving right
here and
i get a lot of money and we're doing
really better
who has had asuelu as their uber driver
that would be such a cool surprise to
get in the car and just see oswello in
the front
anyway all this home shopping sounded
like a good idea
he really thinks that being in our own
place will make him
act differently until kalani revealed to
her sister that she's still considering
divorce
this is basically the last shot i've
done everything that i possibly could to
save my marriage
but because i swallowed set his own
space would make him happier
and make him act better she's now
looking at buying a home as their last
shot to make it work
i want to give it this shot so that if
he doesn't then i could say look
i tried this i tried this i tried this
yeah but then you have a whole ass house
together
so isn't that even harder
i understand what kalini is saying and i
know it's kind of crazy to buy a house
to fix my marriage
i think that me and oswalo have a lot of
issues that need to be addressed
and i think a house can help and him
having his own space can help but i
don't think it's gonna fix everything
then why do it they can save a lot of
money
by figuring out how to not argue where
they are now
it's not impossible i get wanting to
have your own space as a family
but i think the moment you try to use a
house
a ring or a baby to try to fix a
relationship
you always end up doubling your problems
we see what happened with mike and
natalie
now look i love kalani and i respect her
for doing whatever it takes to keep our
family together
but it seems like buying a house is just
them beating around the bush
a very expensive bush at that
hopefully it'll work out the way you
want if it doesn't
i already have your divorce party
planned
what's my color scheme um eat black
obviously yeah for the death of your
marriage
but so it's a funeral for
my marriage divorce yeah all righty
dang kalani looks sad i'm sure it's
beyond stressful to be in constant limbo
like that
bye from me cause i'm the best let's
move on to andre
asking elizabeth's dad to loan him a
hundred thousand dollars
let's start off at the beginning so we
can really see the workings of this
man's mind
andre revealed that he's no longer going
to be a stay-at-home dad
last year i was a homestay dad because
he just got his real estate license
and he's ready to jump in full force i
think i'm going to do great of selling a
house because i know how to
convince people and you know like
everybody should buy from me that's for
sure
let's hear it away from me cause i'm the
best
who is he convincing with that he's
definitely bold
buy from me cause i'm the best i don't
know about convincing it's nice to know
that he's decided to get a job
instead of leaving the load on elizabeth
but let's be honest here
real estate is a tough business it's
really tough you got to be fit for it
things just aren't going to come easy
and it seems like that's what andre
thinks
they look like a cellar houses where
they look like a seller
used cars according to elizabeth's
sister
she's the reason he even got his
there you license you should be giving
me one whole bottle
yeah for helping you get your real
estate license oh my god
i did it on my own and with my own power
you copied me wow right
things started to get uncomfortable
really quick the moment
andre started talking about his master
plan to grow his business flipping
houses
start my own business flipping houses
that master plan includes elizabeth's
dad chuck
who owns a property management company
like i want to ask him like
maybe like a hundred grand you know what
i mean
what are you joking me who do you think
you are
because i need capital and you're like
check is like the money over there so
like why not
aim for the stars you know what i mean
you know it's really annoying
when andre brings up what chug does for
the rest of his kids
track is like romania over there so
those are his kids
he didn't bring you into this family his
daughter did and it also shows that you
just can't do nice things for certain
people
because they will take it in a run with
it
chuck already paid for their unnecessary
moldovan wedding
and according to elizabeth's brother
charlie chuck was also paying for stuff
around their house too
[Music]
i just don't get how you want to demand
all of this respect from everyone
but you're basically asking for a
handout y'all
he really thought it was okay to ask for
money to start a business
that will eventually compete with the
man who loaned him the money
why not aim for the stars you know what
i mean beyond that being arrogant
it's just not smart although it took a
while for elizabeth to speak up
eventually she did she told andre to
take his ego out of it
and just be appreciative of whatever her
dad decides to give him
like i think that you should go into it
with a complete open mind
and be very appreciative with everything
that he
offers you all right i got it
okay how's it going man what's going on
all good yep today i'm meeting with
chuck to
talk about alone and uh i'm really
convincing so
uh i think it's gonna go great i don't
know who told andre he's convincing but
he is really running with it i know he's
gonna say yes
and i'm gonna be one step closer to
starting my own real estate business
once he told chuck that he got his real
estate license and he wants to start
working
chuck initially thought he was asking to
come work for him at the family business
hallelujah how are you which is
something he's tried to get andre to do
before
but then the truth came out a second i
want to make it clear i don't want to
work for your houses
i'm not really following you right now i
want to
get a loan from you you want a loan
like 100 grand maybe
no that ain't happening that ain't
happening
i really can't believe he has the
audacity
to call a meeting and ask me to loan him
a hundred thousand dollars
it's unbelievable really i i don't even
know what to say
chuck's reaction right here says it all
and i don't even know why elizabeth
allowed andre to do that
i know she doesn't control him but i
would be offended
if my man really thought it was okay to
ask my dad for that much money
that's a turn off go out there and work
for it after chuck didn't budge
andre finally humbled himself and agreed
to go work under him to get experience
first
i agree to work with chuck because i
know but
getting a loan it's going to be harder
otherwise but now
the issue is elizabeth's brother charlie
charlie works for chuck as well
and he and andre haven't spoken since
this moldovan wedding moment
next week it looks like he's gonna be
pretty upset to learn that he might
have a new co-worker you might have a
beef with andre but you don't have a
beef with your sister he needs to earn
our
trust him doing this is saying your
family
chill out i'm not gonna let
him take advantage of my family andre's
drama with his family seems like it is
never ending all right 90 day fans fam
to stay updated on all the latest news
coming out the 90 day universe
make sure you stick with e.t because as
usual we are covering it all
i'll see you next time
you